I started working with some of the
sporting events and my name got out
there and then I did they called me to
do a before Regis and Kathy Lee had a TV
show Regis was doing a show on Lifetime
television if you have a lifetime
television oh yeah and they would call
me in and I'd bring in snakes or goats
whatever and so in fact when Regis and
Kathy Lee started their show Kathy Lee
wasn't the host I go before Kathy Lee it
was a lady by the name of Ann Abernathy
and then when when Anne Abernathy left
it was uh uh Steve garvey's wife Cindy
Garvey was the host so Cindy Garvey and
Regis and it was a loco good morning you
knew them back in the day yeah it was it
was a New York show not syndicated then
Buenavista picked it up uh in fact I was
on the demo reel on the demo reel I
brought on like 22 Golden Retriever
puppies how could they blow it so yeah I
did Regis and Kathy Lee for all those
years it was it was a fun show to do
um if you ever get bitten on on a live
show like some dog you I could tell you
have not by a dog I I was doing a snake
I was doing a show in San Francisco it
was a show called Mac and Muttley I just
finished teaching a dog how to scuba
dive for the TV show so anyway I'm doing
this whole thing this is my life Michael
doing this show they'd fly me out to uh
to San Francisco and I do a bunch of
shows at times I finished doing that
then I finished doing this I just did a
segment on rhones now I'm doing a
segment on snakes and the bottom line
was that I didn't get a chance to wash
my hands under my own stupidity I went
to pick up this rattlesnake and I have
the smell of rodents on my hands so he
launched in tonight he launched into me
and I spent two days in the hospital in
San Francisco and had to take you to
know this did you she almost died I
didn't almost die but I was pretty sick
and then I had uh what does it feel like
to be
bitten by a rattlesnake what's that
feeling like the breathing the breathing
the nerves you know the type of toxin
that they have you feel like you're like
I could die I I you want to die it's
that bad yeah it is that bad you want to
die you want to die and it was a young
rattlesnake and the young of the
rattlesnake the more Venom they they
give you you know the oldest snake save
their venom just use enough to deal with
it but the younger ones just they put it
all out there so and then there was a
time I was working I did a TV show in
New York for six years called Saturday
morning live and it was hosted by Gene
Rayburn remember old school he was right
he was my mentor I mean this guy taught
me everything and I was doing a segment
on uh on on lizards and uh before I went
on I was working with an animal called a
big large I don't know I think it was
like
kind of big large furry animal I'm
trying to think of what it was now
anyway it took my finger and it bit me
before I went on the air and 80
something stitches my finger was hanging
and and but I didn't want to miss the
segments adrenaline kept it through it I
I went I we took a break I went back put
a bunch of bandages on put my hand in my
pocket and finished a segment and and
and and but then because I did that show
Jean would have all these friends come
on you know Charles Nelson Riley Betty
White uh all his friends would come on
it was amazing to get to meet Jesus all
of these people that are idled and then
I got called to do our magazine and I'll
come out the Westinghouse out here and I
got to hang out with Liberace help I
helped train pictures you got to send me
these pictures of the post yeah there
was some just great shots it was it was
exciting I look back at it now and and
people say to me what about the dangers
you know I was training guard dogs at
the time as well yeah uh once I had a
gun up my head and once I had a knife at
my throat at Hunts Point Market in the
Bronx I was dropping off a guard dog at
three o'clock in the morning Hunts Point
Market is where the price is going to
buy the fruit you know the fruit vendors
the mavens and so I was dropping a dog
off there to do some protection work and
uh you almost got killed there the guy
pulled a knife on me luckily the dog
reacted good training Warren the dog
reacted grabbed his hand took him down
and we were able to get away